I understand you had a little bit of
unpleasantness recently you had your
your your wisdom teeth but yeah mere
days ago I have off days ago yeah days
ago
how do you feeling well I feel okay now
but in the immediate aftermath I wasn't
I wasn't so good because I'm very
sensitive to chemicals and they gave me
laughing gas they give you laughing yeah
yeah and they were like really relaxed
about it they were like this is nothing
it'll wear off quickly and everyone has
their yeah but immediately when they put
it on I felt myself go cuckoo and and I
started in the middle of the procedure I
kept asking the woman who was doing the
procedure is time passing and she was
like yeah it's always passed thing and
then I was like but now what about now
is it passing now and she said well
times the constructs so maybe we're
moving in time is standing still that is
some deep thinking dead yeah it was very
frightening but it was exciting and then
when I got out I was still high because
I it lasted a long time and my mom was
there and she picked me up and I was so
punchy that we got into the garage where
my car was and we passed these two kind
of like frat guys and I said in full
voice to my mom I went get a load of
these
[Laughter]
just like stop jack get in the car let's
get you a cup of coffee she's like
you're bleeding on the street so I
eventually got on the car now were you
you were anxious about are you anxious
about having this procedure beforehand
yeah because I knew I had this today and
I was worried that I was gonna be messed
up still right so I I didn't know if I'd
be able to talk so I thought like well
if I'm mute I got a record I recorded
you a message right after because before
the drugs were off I thought once the
drugs were off maybe I can't talk so
I'll make a message for Conan now so
that if I can't talk he'll have a
message so wait so you recorded a
message to me right after while you're
still under the effects of the laughs I
guess right after I called this guy's
yeah the video for you this is
this is real that's real I haven't seen
this so I want to see this let's take a
look at you this is moments after having
your wisdom teeth out let's take a look
oh I'm coming my mouth at the Muir woman
thank you for doing that trace of course
that you were worried about me at that
time I was very I was very concerned I
got in the car and I was like I have to
make a message for Conan yeah I mom was
like maybe we should get home first yeah
you